[Music]
joining me today is an author a
screenwriter the host of the Andrew
Clavin show and one of the few sane
people on the Internet
Andrew Clavin welcome back to the Reuben
report thank you it's nice to be here I
love your new studio thanks well you
were one of the last guests before we
built this home studio and we had you on
at a very odd time because it was right
before the election but we were going to
air it after the election because I had
to pad some shows because I were we were
building this so I and perhaps you two
went on the assumption that Hilary was
going to win and and then people
immediately after we aired it said you
got to get Clavin back on because you
guys got it got to clean this whole
thing up so you ready to do some
cleaning I'm ready I'm here all right so
where was our first I do consider you
one of the few same people that I that
speaks ill of you yeah but I can Sicily
every time I watch one of your clips or
I see what you're tweeting about you
strike me as just you basically strike
me as decent which these days I think
has a correlation between decency and
sanity that's a lot of pressure I'm
giving you know it is sad that being
decent actually elevates you love the
concern these days but but you know it's
the thing with me is that I have I can
say I can state what my principles are I
can I try to follow my principles I try
not to get too mixed up with
personalities which in this day and age
with a president like Trump with like
the people around you around him makes
things a lot clearer you know because
that's what people are paying attention
to they're paying attention to the big
faces the paying attention to that he
said this and she said that and I'm just
like trying to follow that principle
would I know what it is and I'm trying
to follow that thing yeah so I think I
come from a similar place and I think
you know our politics which do line up
in a lot of ways not not fully but that
that's what I try to go for where do you
think that comes from within you that
you don't go for all that other stuff
that that's so many people are you well
in me it's actually a matter of time
observing over time what works what
doesn't work and also you know it's just
been a basic maybe it was the time I was
raised in but has been a basic principle
of me that people
mind that people should be free that you
should be free that you are you know
made by God to be a free person that the
things that are happening inside you
that are expressed in your and the
things that you like and the things that
you want to say and your opinions on
that all those things are uniquely
valuable and even if you're a jackass
even if you're saying stuff that makes
me want to strangle you you know if
you're a racist or something like this I
think that there's something uniquely
valuable about that and I know that it's
more important than some guy in
Washington who knows better than you and
I think the text that's always been my
assumption it was I was raised in that
all-american way I was raised in the
suburbs in the early sixties you know
it's just that was kind of what that was
a civic religion and it always seemed
good to me and then when things changed
I would listen to the arguments and I
found you know I've developed and the
things get are different over time but
certain principles stay the same and if
you stick with that you basically I
don't know you know it's a question of
actually enjoying other people and even
when they can be jerks sometimes I like
them you know I'd like yeah you can
enjoy sitting across from someone that
you don't agree with saying that you can
do that this is the thing when you know
whenever I see on YouTube it says so it
so destroys no matter how my god it says
so it so talks to someone else yeah big
letters you know because it yeah when
you talk to people you disagree with if
they don't get angry at you and they're
not shouting at you you know you learn a
lot of stuff and you can and and you
hone your own arguments and sometimes on
occasion you change your mind I mean I'm
a I would say if I had to place myself
in the political spectrum might be a
libertarian but one of the reasons I
changed on abortion took 20 years but I
had an argument with a guy and I lost it
all right and I thought like you know
what I can't defend my position against
this guy yeah
as a great teachable moment it's a real
teachable moment and it reminds you to
listen to people now I like that you
just used the phrase Civic religion
because one of the things I've been
talking about on here is that to me
leftism has become a secular religion
yes I've had a couple people mention
this idea Peter pegasion was on a couple
weeks ago who really explained it well
but that basically the
has become this infallible doctrine that
you must never leave my and if you do
leave you're going to basically have a
fatwa on your head right but a civic
religion is an interesting phrase
because basically you were just your
civic religion in that regard was just
live and let live well we're pretty much
yes amazing and and the idea that you
know that the more government there is
the less people a person there is you
know that the fact that a woman comes
into a town and says oh I know how to do
people's hair and the government says we
need a permit for that we need a permit
to do hair do you know that that's it's
just kind of ongoing if the bald guy
issue right yeah well you know you read
those occasional stories where some
little kid is a lemonade stand every eye
off you know because he was never firm I
mean that is the stuff that is so
offensive to me and it's like I guess
over time I've kept watching people who
told me that they were trying to make
the world more free and more fair but it
always turned out not always but it
often turned out that what they were
really trying to do is take the power
away from someone they felt was
oppressing them and take it themselves
so that they could oppressing a person
who had been oppressing and I have like
just steadfastly maintained that like I
want the world to be more free and more
fair I'm perfectly willing to accept
that somebody's been marginalized and
needs to be included but I'm not willing
to force this other guy to like it or to
include him or to serve him or do
anything else it just seems to me that
freedom is a balance yeah you mentioned
something very briefly about God now
last time you were on yeah we did sort
of your whole evolution which is really
kind of fascinating you were born Jewish
then you were atheist for what a bulk of
your five years were thirty-five Gnostic
atheist yeah and then about how old are
you and you then I was I was about 45
when I became atheist when I start to
believe in God and I was just about 50
when I was baptized and yeah so how I
just had your friend Dennis Prager on oh
yeah my friend Dennis Prager and and
Michael Shermer do you know Michael
mentioned Michael who runs a skeptic
magazine oh yes we had a great
conversation about belief and morality
with God or without that it was really
great at the end we all agreed wow how
nice we can fit
woman not agree on everything and we
might have dinner together you know but
for you as someone that's you know
traveled in and out of religion how
important is the idea of religion as a
foundational belief for society well the
only reason to believe in religion as
far as I'm concerned is because it's
true okay that's the only reason so the
idea that it's good for society or it is
or it conducive to law and order
conducive to politeness and I'm not
interested in believing the fantasy just
because it works and I've always hated
arguments based on practicality when it
comes to metaphysics significant to me
you can be a nice person obviously
without being without being a theist at
all or plenty of nice atheists lovely
people who are atheist but but I do
believe that most of what you think is
true is illogical without religion
without God and many people don't follow
their own thoughts down to the ground
and this is true of both atheists and
believers and I do believe that here's
what I think has happened to us I think
that you know right around the 17th
century that science became science
became what we know it today and certain
questions were put aside in order to do
science so in other words you had people
saying hey I can measure this and I can
predict this and then I can heal this
and I can build this and all these
things are such a great you know
obviously such a great benefit to
society from the iphone the penicillin
whatever you're talking about all the
stuff has revolutionized human life it
was assumed and it was argued that there
was an underlying logic to science which
precluded God which eliminated God even
though most of the people who invented
science were Christians it was a presume
that there was an underlying logic so in
other words they say there's evolution
and if there's evolution everything is
random and you go well okay this
evolution but random you can't tell
randomness from within a system you
can't say I'm in a system it is random
because obviously the order of us every
system comes from outside the system
I believe that logic is starting to
collapse I
that logic has played out and I believe
this has been sold to us and the
materialism the basically materialism
that everything is material everything
as a material cost the material
explanation is better than that that I
believe is toxic because it doesn't make
sense
because you cannot get from morality to
materialism and from materialism to
morality that I believe has had a toxic
effect on our society and so I don't
want to replace materialism with theism
because I think it's toxic I want to do
it because I think the truth is healing
and liberating so without going too far
down just specifically the the rabbit
hole of belief we've done it a bunch on
the show and I think I find it even for
for atheists and believers everyone kind
of gets to a point where it's like all
right well I
the good ones that we use get to a point
where it's like all right well that's
what I believe and it framed some other
stuff so let's talk about that so
without going too far down that rabbit
hole if you think that that those
systems are collapsing is that is that
really a metaphor or or a bridge to why
so many systems seem like they're
collapsing right now yes media politics
I think that's exactly what's happening
I I will sit here and predict to you
that I believe in the next actually I
believe it's happening now but I believe
it will erupt at some point that there's
going to be an intellectual revival of
it's really a risk to Tyrion thought the
idea that we're here we have a purpose
other than that bottle has a purpose
that this body has a purpose this mind
has a purpose that is already coming
back and when you talk to people it's
really interesting when you go in to the
top universities and you talk to young
people there who are the best minds of
the country they're all believers and
I'll believe in God which wouldn't have
been true I think 30 40 years ago and
this is because ideas play themselves
out over time and this idea that the
world is material is ending and yes I
think a lot of the craziness we're
saying and they you know I hate talking
about some of these extraordinary
political things because it sounds like
you're being mean like it sounds like
when I say if a man has an operation
then turns himself into a woman he's not
a woman that's a statement of fact in my
to my mind it doesn't be abused or
bullied or
or anything like that so totally
different quota but some of these
questions where reality is starting to
disappear I think are built into the
fact that this idea is collapsing it's
so interesting because I do believe that
trans people exist any mean I'm not
saying a lot yeah I don't think you said
that they don't exist but that but that
I believe that it is it is a actual say
it's a it's an actual existential thing
for this particular rhythm and I think
but yet I can still go with you in that
place because it seems like the hysteria
constantly surrounding it is making
people question everything you know do
you mean like if you don't accept trans
people the second that everyone else
accepts them or not even accepts them
because I think most people except them
but if you don't celebrate it
immediately or wish for an isle it's
like they they will turn on you guys
you're a trend I think of the things
that to give a child to hormone
treatments or any kind of operation
based on some kind of stated preference
that I believe is abusive that I believe
is wrong but for an adult to decide that
he wants to live his life in any way he
wants is only not hurting anybody
it means it means nothing to me I mean
it just means nothing to me but but when
he says to me you must call me a woman
then he is taking away my right to
experience reality as I experience it
and that's where he loses his rights
this strikes me as you're sort of like a
mature Republican you know anyway like
that's what it drives me I was like
because everything you just said makes
sense within a conservative viewpoint
yeah you know within a libertarian
conservative viewpoint except there's so
few conservatives willing to say that
what you just said well you know it's
funny you asked me at the very beginning
how I kept hold of some of these
principles and it didn't occur to me
until just a moment ago as we were
taught so I'm one of these I'm a
novelist I've lived most of my life
right here animals and when you're a
novel it's what you do is you create
characters and each one of these
characters has a full complete existence
and a full complete justification even
when you're inventing the bad guy you
realize that in his mind the world makes
perfect sense and he makes perfect sense
in that world and I'll actually think of
people that way yeah maybe that's a
novelist training or maybe you start out
with that and it turns you into a
novelist
actually think of people that way I
actually think of somebody who says to
me I'm having this inner experience of
being alienated from my sex or whatever
whatever it is I know that that doesn't
officially be outdone I mean that seems
like I feel it might be painful and it
offends me if he says that I have to
react in a certain way or this guy has
to react by law on a certain way but his
experience is like it really is part of
the kind of fabric of the world and I
think I think that there has been too
many people on both sides have conflated
what government does with how we live so
in other words I've had this argument
with conservatives a lot where they'll
they'll say well they want to legalize
marijuana and I'll say it's fine just
don't let people drive with marijuana
you know and like what you want to
poison yourself I think it's bad for you
but you know it's not my business go
ahead do you think Madeline is that I do
think it's bad for you but what I've
read it's bad for you but I don't use it
so I don't really know that much about a
pen you don't seem to want to stop
someone from you thank you
why would I want to stop somebody from
using it except except if if I were you
I might say Dave you know I've read some
articles not good for you whatever but
then then you know it's coming from me
and you can say whether the vape pen
there's finished that even reserved for
loans come on but this is the thing
government should not have the right to
approve or disapprove it only has the
right to protect me from you it
shouldn't protect me from me if I want
to throw myself off a bridge you know do
I think that's right no but I should be
able to throw myself off a bridge what I
shouldn't be able to do I the best
example I always use is the seatbelts
versus a cell phone you know when you
use a cell phone in a car you're
endangering mate when using it don't use
your seatbelt you want to fly away to a
Hilton none of my business
yeah and then you know I know that
libertarians take some extreme crazy
positions but in general free markets
free minds seems to me the the way
forward so I do see the the freedom
thing gaining traction yes sure even the
way that I've talked a lot obviously
about classical liberalism and
libertarianism and all of this I see
that now I see it I just see it in
society and on social media I see it
more in a cooler fashion that it would
be
maybe coming from Ted Cruz or something
like I see it's gaining a little
traction in a bigger way
I'm not certainly not all because of me
obviously all because you liked what you
said about that they'll be an
intellectual resurgence too because I
think starting to see a little bit of
that but it's starting to feel cool to
have knowledge again as opposed to the
15 years of endless reality TV and just
the worst of us constantly and endless
bickering and one-upping I think we're
starting to turn a corner on that which
which I've been waiting for for a long
time well I mean it's an awful you know
I recently spoke I don't get to speak
too often at places but partly because I
ignore the requests and now now I have
somebody who does it so maybe I'll speak
but I spoke at Overland recently which
is a deeply like the heart of liberal
darkness yeah and and and I went in
there and I was I thought that these
children who did my age they now look
like children you know I felt that they
were being almost abused by their
heritage of knowledge of wisdom was
being taken away from them that if you
know you should come out of college you
should have read some Shakespeare you
know and you should have read all some
of the great writers you should know
some of these great thinkers Plato and
people like that and you should know
them without the professor standing
between you and the guy you know
Shakespeare has traveled through time
400 years to bring you the wisdom au n--
equation of the world I don't need a
professor doing anything but explaining
the context to me you know and they have
this thing called fury notice and on you
know at Auckland there were it was a
black dorm I mean Martin Luther King
would roll over in his grave you know
there was there were kids who showed up
you know kind of aggressively displaying
their sexual proclivities and then
heckling me from the crowd and and I
kept saying you know what hold your
question and I'm going to I'm going to
discuss everything you want to discuss
and then the minute I finished and
talking they ran away yeah you know and
I thought like these are that something
it's just right there you know it
and what was interesting was a lot of
the liberal kids who are just ordinary
liberals they stayed and we had really
good conversations only the hecklers ran
away yeah and and so I just think these
kids are being deprived of being
deprived of their intellectual heritage
they're being deprived of the idea that
that I can't fix their problems what
they're being told is that they're
unhappy because they be unhappy because
the way I treat them or you treat them
or society treats them I'm happy because
of things inside themselves and then
what's a differences this gay guy
yelling at me the whole time and at one
point I mentioned to somebody else
in another context I was actually a
supporter of a right and he let out the
slob wolf thank you I said but yeah I
thought people don't like you because
you're gay they don't like it it a zero
loud that's what equality is all about
that you just want people to be equal so
that you can treat them as shitty as you
feed everybody else I don't want a
special treatment for being gay in any
respect
give me equal treatment and now judge me
accordingly exactly and I think this
this has come you know the I see guys
like this Tamaki see Coates mm-hmm and
he writes things there son you need you
need to be made good for the sins of the
past what a terrible thing to tell a
trial nobody can solve the sins of the
past that's the whole point of the past
it's past you know and you cannot fix
the things that we're done to people you
cannot fix history you can't pay people
back the things that happen to people
who are dead
you know the that's the that's the
tragedy of a fallen world you know that
things are written into the fabric of
life and to tell somebody that but he's
not going to be happy until he gets paid
back for slavery or whatever it is it's
condemning him to misery
yeah it's your family because it never
stopped the payback the payback whatever
it is there's never a moment where you
go okay well we got to where we're
supposed to get and now we don't need
anything else anymore it just by human
logic it doesn't make sense and this
used to be the question of Education
what is the good life what's conducive
to happiness what is you know what makes
you miserable
that used to be what you discuss and it
can't the answer can't be my happiness
depends on you be nice to me
you're going to be what you are you know
I'm curious what was what group invited
you at Overland they some it was a bunch
of Republicans it was like the 15
Republicans yet I won't watch I kind of
surprise babies wanted a 16th guy to
finally show up
they were like they were like trolls you
know they were kind of they wanted me to
come and make fun of the left and I
didn't and I thought they even though
the whole thing wouldn't be incredibly
well I actually just talked about ideas
and people listened and I thought well
that's a victory right but I felt that
the Conservatives are so sick of being
shouted at that they've just turned into
into trolls they want to mock the other
side yeah which i think is kind of
interesting because I say all the time
but I only get invited now to colleges
by the Young Republicans or the
libertarians and some other students for
liberty or cutters cetera all of these
things that are technically right even
though they don't they don't seem to
mind them gay married and pro-choice and
against the death penalty and a litany
of everything and then it's like well
who is the tolerance I die I don't get
any advice from anyone no no Young
Democrats or progressives of tomorrow
have ever called me a bit like they you
know we actually see you criticizing our
side but let's come and talk about it
but I'm getting a ton of love from those
other guys who by the way you're right
there's a lot of trolls in that debate
they've started being the funny people
too that's when she's crazy that for you
as a screenwriter and a guide it's
bounced between Hollywood and politics
is that fascinating to you though that
it's also why you are starting to become
funny it's a joy I mean I always my joke
used to be that the reason conservatives
aren't funny is because liberals have no
sense of you but but it is it is a joy
to see conservatives becoming funny and
becoming the the people of freedom
because let's face it conservatism in
the old style did have it's oppressive
elements and it did have its kind of you
know when whenever people are in charge
of the culture as conservatives were
until the 60s basically you know they
abuse that control that's part of that's
part of power corrupting and there was
that element in and there still is among
conservatives that somehow you know you
are destroying the Republic by not being
exactly you know a Bible beating
Christian
whatever it is and and that's just
largely lifted you know I mean so this
is actually an effect I would say a
positive effect that the 60s revolution
is having conservatives is they to have
loosened up nobody wants to go back to
wearing ties to baseball games nobody
wants to go back to you know a rigid
life where you can't be look I take
feminism feminism right now to me like
environmentalism is largely the enemy
they are the feminists are insane
they're not about you know actual sexual
relations between people just like the
environmentalists aren't actually about
conservation and all this stuff but
nobody wants to go back to a world where
a woman does not can't choose what life
she wants I mean I always say to people
if you draw a circle it's called
individualism and a circle that's called
feminism in that place with the Venn
diagram I meet you know I'll agree with
feminism everything outside of that I
don't agree with but nobody wants to go
back to the world where a woman can't be
fully whoever she wants to be and nobody
wants us certainly wants to go back to a
racially segregated world except the
left right they oddly are the ones that
are pushing these things likewise
described at Oberlin and so and so the
modern right is to some degree a
function of certain things that left us
have also brought to the table and have
now become the party of freedom the
party of hilarity you know I mean you do
not laugh a lot when you're around left
us and we imagine when you watch
Samantha be until it's not funny you
know it's not funny it's been painful
it's better better Trump being Trump
okay I'm going to put in the a right and
they have to brief Hipps so even if
Polly meant anything to you last you a
little exciting practice yeah yeah no
this is this is the funny thing about it
is like it when you hear them doing that
at the cursing and anger Marie a lot of
laughter so then when you see people on
the right so like a Jeff Sessions who
there's a lot of talk that he's going to
go in and try to close medical marijuana
dispensaries now you just made it very
clear you don't smoke marijuana you
prefer everything being equal with
people didn't for health reasons and I
think there's a lot of debate around
that but I'm just going with with what
you said when you see that as a small
government guy
a states rights guy and a libertarian
that must be the part of the right that
you don't like right yeah I don't even
know why you would bother with that I
mean I I don't know why there should be
medical marijuana dispensaries why
shouldn't just be like a liquor store
you know you can't buy it if you're not
18 or whatever the proper age is and you
can't use it behind the wheel of a car
and all those things and then we get the
tax taxes you know and get all that
money so I don't know why that should be
what's bothering him you know I mean I I
really like Jeff Sessions I'm a pro Jeff
Sessions guy I think he's going to be a
great AG you know I think he's going to
do but are you concerned about that
state stuff because to me that's one of
the biggest issues the states rights
yeah absolutely
absolutely and one of the things that's
kind of a joy about the Trump era is all
these liberal states suing the federal
government cuz I think I win that either
way either win because the federal
government gets the conservative thing
in there or I win because they get
States right so yeah and that's why the
whole have now been saying every week I
mean the whole chessboard is just
throwing up the traditional left-right
thing barely makes sense it's
authoritarians and libertarians and
allies you know coming together in some
interesting spot I describe it as like
being in a room where the gravity has
gone out of the room and all the
furniture around and you know you don't
know where it's going to land and I
understand some of these guys on
National Review and even my pal Ben
Shapiro you know I understand they're
they're worried about where the
furniture may fall I'm kind of
optimistic and I'm not sure how much of
that is constitutional how much of it is
observational you know right but I do
feel that good things are coming I look
to the generations down the line and
what I see coming up is kind of a
cultural liberalism which I agree with
but but an understanding that freedom is
economic and freedom is governmental and
if the government can tell you what to
like and what to do you know it's just
it's it's not you're not free yeah and
they're not that smart
[Music]
you